[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now silver
state schools credit union guides its
members at every stage of life
here's more on how they prioritize
people over profit
[Music]
at silver city schools credit union we
prioritize people over profit
because our members are our owners and
they're at the center of everything that
we do
whether it's investing in something
that's most important to them
in their life or investing in some way
into the community
we always want to put our members first
we're definitely multi-generational in
the products that we serve
whether that's for the young child
that's literally counting
learning how to count to 10 or to the
seasoned
savvy adult who is looking for
investment accounts
so we start off with our junior accounts
and that's for
children that are under 18 and we are
literally teaching them
how to save and about banking products
in general
or we have the my account checkings and
savings accounts for 18 to 25 year olds
for people who might be starting their
first job
going off to college or just want to
learn more about how to plan for their
financial future
we're currently at our samurai branch
and we have 10 local branches in the las
vegas valley area but our members have
access to their silver state schools
credit union
accounts from almost anywhere not only
do we offer simple and secure online and
mobile
banking options but we also have
partnered with the co-op network
and the all point network to give our
members over 5000
sure branch locations and 85 000
surcharge free
atms nationwide it's really a great way
for our members who travel frequently
or are attending college or even decide
to move out of the area but still want
to keep their banking account
with silver state schools credit union
you don't just have to be a teacher to
be a member at silver state schools
credit union in fact
almost anyone can be a member at silver
state schools credit union
whether you're a teacher an
administrator
a school staff you're eligible and also
parents and guardians for all children
enrolled in nevada education programs
are also eligible
one of my favorite things to mention
however is by making a one-time donation
to vegas pbs
you can also become a member at silver
state schools credit union
as you know vegas pbs is very integrated
with the education system here
in the las vegas valley so it's a great
way to both support vegas pbs as well as
become a member at silver state schools
credit union
silver state schools credit union you
can give them a call at
or 702-733-8820 visit
silverstatesilverstatecu.com kendall
sent over to you